in Bremer's founding president Eurasia
Group a global risk consulting company
good morning
I'll be with you guys so give us a sense
of what are the risk on this trip what
are the opportunities on this trip and
what does the president hope to
accomplish other than getting away from
domestic problems well look I mean I
think this is a very well-put-together
trip in terms of Trump's capabilities
right yeah almost any president goes to
Canada or Mexico the last seven have all
gone Canada Mexico he's not doing is
going to Saudi Arabia but the Saudis and
the Israelis are the two leaders in the
world that most wanted to see the back
of President Obama right in terms of
American allies and so they're really
happy to see Trump this is not these are
the easy trips they layup they're going
to announce all sorts of new cooperation
they will be personally warm physically
warmth will be a lot of pomp showing
Trump what a great guy he is big
celebrations and they'll make some
announcements new arms deals for example
new cooperation on security Trump just
had another bombing run against some
allies of Assad yesterday showing that
he's doing more to support the Saudis in
the region this shouldn't be hard but as
you say you know this is kind of a
disaster first he steps on himself
constantly he's now done that
domestically with enormous scandals that
aren't going to go away while he's on
this trip he's going to have to take
those questions deal with those
headlines can't help himself with the
tweets and also he's likely to say some
things that will be embarrassing and
off-camera moments that become on-camera
moments and leaks over the course of
this trip final thing I would say on
this is you know this is his first trip
as president to the Islamic world he's
going to be giving a speech where I'm
sure he's going to say many times
radical Islamic terror something Obama
wasn't willing to say god forbid we have
a terrorist attack against Americans in
the region while he's doing that clearly
that would be a very attractive target
for terrorist organizations I think we
have to be cognizant of that so what
will be the definition of success for
you with this trip for him well I think
if we can just kind of get through the
media cycle and write other than that
though in than that I mean is there
something concrete that you can say that
was a good trip he did
well look I think the fact that he now
has foreign policy advisors around him
that have gotten him to normalize on a
bunch of things remember how China went
before the big China meeting he was
saying you're manipulating currency I
might be working with the Taiwanese
afterwards hey we're buddies now right
what we need on this trip is that kind
of a showing that when the president is
in a meeting with a major leader but
know we're working with NATO now no I
know I said I wanted a week year but
actually I'm okay with Makran I'm okay
with Merkel we haven't just improved
body language but actually I recognize
the transatlantic relationship is
important and again with Saudi and with
Israel you know as long as there are no
massive distractions these are meetings
set up to go well and with the Pope I'd
say don't do a campaign they had a
little bit of a spat they did but the
fact that was mostly on Trump right I
mean I the Pope is not gonna try to
embarrass Trump in that meeting so I
think that would Beca go easy and you
say Saudi and Israel or lamps for this
president but you point out the rift
that he has with a lot of European
leaders you don't think that there's a
certain amount of trepidation if you are
a member of NATO or if you are a member
of the EU looking at this president and
the surfeit of scandals he's dealing
with here in the United States well I
mean Rex Tillerson Secretary of State
came out just yesterday and said hey
outside the United States people aren't
really they're too busy they're not
thinking about this I can tell you that
is not that's not remotely plausible
every foreign minister I have personally
met with spoken with since Trump has
been elected the first thing they asked
me what the hell is happening with your
president right so they're extremely
concerned about it but at the same time
you know it's not like NATO has a plan B
instead of the United States Americans
doing the lifting this is clear an
opportunity for him to try to say to
Islam leaders in all those countries I
am NOT anti-muslim yes in a speech as
well as meeting for them and also try to
bring them in to do something to bring
the out Israelis and the Palestinians
together
good luck they're doing one okay but but
but yeah they're coming together for
this and they both have a stake in yes
look and he said Jared's in charge of
making the peace to happen I'm
desperately skeptical that anything can
be done in Israel Palestine today given
the Israeli government the limitations
on Palestine I believe that when John
Kerry made his ill-fated 12 trips to try
to make that happen but but they're more
committed to a relationship with Trump
than they were John Israeli certainly
are we accept that Saudis - yeah I think
that it's too entrenched that that's a
step too far I mean if Trump can just
get through the meetings then this is I
don't think this is a president that
we're saying can we get a Nobel Peace
Prize I think the president we're saying
yet do the can we have a good trip and I
think as we saw what she champagne you
know he has real vulnerabilities on
Islam right and it there is also a lot
to be said for his own base in going
after I'm gonna make you secure the
Saudis are a good place to do that the
Saudis don't have to worry about
internal you know sort of ratings
whatsoever there aren't going to be
demonstrations at all they're going to
make it a very comfortable place he's
going to give a big speech and the
Saudis will say that was a great speech
to make you in and Bremer always good to
see you following that trip closely